[music]
[music] [music] [
music]
[music]
Dear All, Welcome to all of you.
On this auspicious day, family and friends gather together to
wish our dear and precious birthday.  I would
like to congratulate you first, let me introduce myself [music] [music]
You've finally come.
]
Ladies and gentlemen, we are waiting for an important lady to board. Please
welcome us with a big round of applause.
Thank you for your participation.
[Music] Let's get
excited together next time at that place
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] It's
finally
settled down here How are you?  Keep it in your
hands Force your quibbles on us and tie us up I'll get rid of you
today
Give me back
Don't think it's easy to meet You
fools who were lured out
Everyone will be
arrested
[Music]
[Music] I managed to
hide it.  The
boss of the sea is still on the run, but it doesn't matter if the
quest is completed for the time being Cass
's true identity has been
exposed The
fake Nyanko Sea already exists,
and the fu-a kid must be safe
[music]
Nara Restaurant  But you don't have to open it Please
sleep well I have work tomorrow too
[music] [music] [music] [music
]
[music]